in Mali as Scotland's only Labour MP and
a candidate to be the party's deputy
leader and guess what mr. Mali joins me
in the studio but a good morning to you
just of course speaking to Allen
McCluskey of unite they're at
disappointed not to get the nomination
and get the support from unite well I
didn't expect to get the support from
unite but I'm disappointed that I've not
got the support of any trade unions yet
but we're working very hard on that
we've had very lively hustings we've
discussed the issues and I've been very
clear to everyone who's got a vote in
this leadership contest that if they
want continuity which is what I think
Len McCluskey was offering there and
he's interview not to vote for me I have
to be the change candidate because the
country is screaming out for the Labour
Party to change what in your view is is
is the job of the deputy leader of the
Labour Party because in Lang mikorskis
view in his own words above all it is to
show loyalty to the leader well it's to
organize the party and that's one of the
reasons I've decided to stand because I
when my marginal seat by building a
broad coalition of support by
organisation I'm going to take that
across the whole of the party and yes
their deputy leader should unite the
party and be loyal to the leader but
should also be a critical friend if
you're going to be the voice of the
membership and the voice of the trade
unions and the affiliates and the labor
movement sometimes you'll have to have
those hard conversations with the leader
as well so it's a critical friend but a
loyal friend as well in terms of as
who's discussing discussing with mr.
McClosky that the the Board of Deputies
pledges should those that refuse to sign
up to that should they even be standing
in this contact well there's a much
wider at issue here actually it's not
really just about the board of deputy
pledges which you know I have signed
it's about that all of the Jewish
organizations community is coming
together to try and help us to find a
system to read the Labour Party of the
cancer of anti-semitism never again
should we be going into an election
where are you knock on a door and
somebody says they're not voting for the
Labour Party for the first time in their
life because of anti-semitism is what
I'm talking about you know I'm saying
that she'd done Butler
be in this contest should Richard Bergen
be in this contest given that
anti-semitism as you know was an issue
on the doorstep that it is still an
issue around Labor's now well I would
encourage people to not party that heads
in the sand with us anymore and the key
thing for adeptia leader has to be to
take some of these issues on and I've
pledged that if I do become deputy
leader I want every single case of
anti-semitism and other bullying and
harassment claims in the party on my
desk every week to make sure they're
being dealt
and then look at if we can work with a
Jewish community and the Jewish
organizations to provide a better system
to make sure they're dealt with
effectively and I think people should
take their head out of the sand and just
deal with this there's no longer she'd a
Labour Party be walking on the other
side of the street when minority
communities in this country are
screaming out the Labour Party to do
something that's in the national
interest in their interest and that's to
read the party of the cancer of
anti-semitism it's as simple and
straightforward as that so what do you
offer that the other candidates in this
contest don't
well I offer a number of things the
first thing is that I do when my
marginal seat by building that broad
coalition of support one of the best
things that's ever been said to me was I
only win my seat by getting Liberal
Democrat and Tory voters to vote for me
well that seems to me campaigning 101 I
want to do that right across the country
I'm also bringing that Scottish voice I
think it's important for the Labour
Party to send a message to all the
nations and regions of the United
Kingdom that they matter they told us
during the election campaign and then
they've run up to the 12th of December
that they didn't think the Labour Party
cared about them and the third thing is
I want to take on this big issue of the
Constitution we need to see where power
lies in this country and of course
bricks at Brennan and that's why I'd
like to launch live a campaign for
Britain's future which isn't just about
where power lies within the nations and
regions of the United Kingdom but hope
her right lies with the relationship of
the European Union and the wider
international community but is it
possible for any deputy leader you
included to advocate for labour once
again being a rather broader churched
to looking to taking votes from the
Liberal Democrats and the Conservatives
that you will need if you're going to
get back into into number 10 if the
leader is not of a similar mindset if
there is an ideological purity that's
being pursued in favour over over you
know simply getting in to number 10 well
we have to be a credible alternative
government or our diminishing party of
Perpetual opposition and we have to be
the former and to be the former all
those people that didn't vote labour on
the turth of December have to change
their vote and put across in the labour
box there's a lot of what to be done
there may have to listen to what the
public are telling us and that's what I
want to do we should go to the seats
that we lost the seats that we won even
the seats that we've never won to listen
to what the public are saying and mulder
Labour Party around labour party values
to put a programme in front of them that
they feel as if they want to reconnect
where the scale of the challenge is huge
if we only return one Scottish Labour MP
at the next election we will have to
when Jacob
Molk seat in North East Somerset as a
13% swing has unparalleled and
unprecedented in electoral history not
just in this country but in most
countries across the Western world so
that is the scale of the challenge and
unless we face up to that challenge we
will never win again how do you regain
as a party regain your footing in
Scotland given that you are absolutely
apocalyptic scenes this election given
the party stance on brexit and
Scotland's view of brexit given the
party's view did I say at a second
independence referendum how do you get
them back well the key thing here is the
party should never face both ways on
these big constitutional issues because
principally we're against independence
for Scotland because we don't think it's
and the national interests and
principally we're against brexit because
we don't think it's in the national
interest the next 12 months will decide
whether or not we were correct or wrong
on the bricks you don't see an
inconsistency with you know saying no to
leaving between those two positions I
mean there's are there any circumstances
in which you yourself would say fight a
second independence referendum should
and will no be grant well that's not for
me to decide and I think valves are
talking about procedural issues and the
process stories here we're missing the
big issues around actually what Scottish
independence mean it would mean for
Scotland I would rather we talked about
why were principally against
independence and the reasons why were
behind it rather than the technicalities
of section 5 of the Scotland Act of 1998
that nobody knows what's in it and the
section of theater that would be
required or just on that I mean if the
SNP got a majority in 2021 at the
Scottish Parliament would they then be
allowed to have a second independence
referendum well that'd be up to the
Prime Minister to decide but once you
doing everything we possibly can to mean
well we're going to we're going to
hypothetical scenarios I mean so John
Kotter's who's the no doubt the UK's
most prominent pooling expert has said
that you can't extrapolate the election
results of the 12th of December into
seeing that anyone's got a mandate for
calling another independence referendum
in fact the exceed whose cause he said
that elect a parliament in 2020 but the
only reason I'm asking all of this is
that sometimes it strikes me that people
are opposed to a second independence
referendum at all costs yet I wonder if
I were to ask you whether or not there
should be a vote about as reentering the
European Union you might have a
different view on that well the bottom
line here is that you've got to be
principally against something or
principally for something I think it's
incumbent on
labor movement to have a much more
positive view not just on the United
Kingdom and why Scott Lee should be part
of the United Kingdom but our outlook to
the rest of the world and the next 12
months will determine what that should
look like it's an incredibly important
debate for us to have and I should be
leading that debate as a deputy leader
of the party but the key thing here in
terms of whether or not someone should
have a referendum if we just think back
to David Cameron back in 2013 he didn't
really want a yiyu referendum but I bet
the entire farm on an EU referendum and
lost and therefore if we disagree with
the ends let's not facilitate the means
Minh were principally against it
and while we're doing everything we
possibly can not only to prevent an SMP
majority in 2021 but to deliver the
Labour government in Scotland I'm gonna
be slightly cheeky here and I wonder
whether our Labour's kind of saw
Scottish representative in the Commons
you are the the best person to lead that
particular argument given that there is
one rather big skeleton in your closet
or our rather I should actually say that
suits if we bring up the picture suit in
your wardrobe what's this all about
well I can tell you exactly sorry I'm
getting palpitations this has followed
me around for years and it's fun that
was that Glastonbury and I'm gonna do an
advert for you cuz we're on Sky not the
BBC company called opera suits that go
to Glastonbury every year I was going
and what you can do you can get a
picture of your wedding you get a TV
test car didn't get dayglo orange I was
leafing through and they said look what
size are you no I said I think I'm a 42
they went well try this on and that was
the only 42 they had I've tried it on
you only need to be caught in a zip line
waving - exactly well we've got a
photograph taken and of course I said
that photograph should never go anywhere
and of course that Glastonbury after of
huge ciders you tend to be a little bit
more looser with your Twitter feed and
it's full of me and we're sure the MP
for Perth are not special I'll love you
for having that for the graph one you
believe it or not I do I believe it and
the relevance of this of course is the
big dividing line between Scotland and
England has for a time being Bing brexit
so what hope the Scottish Labour half of
avoiding an increased push for
independence without a better position
as to what happens regarding brexit well
the first thing is in terms of breaks at
the next 12 months we'll determine what
happens and everything that no happens
over the next 12 months
lies firmly at the door of number 10 in
Boris Johnson's promises that he's made
to the electorate so that's the first
thing the second thing is we have to set
the bar really high in terms of what
breaks it's you know look like it can't
just be about stopping your deal which
is important we must be setting the bar
high in terms of workers rights consumer
rights environmental protections
security and safety of the UK and the
third thing is all the wrongheaded
arguments that myself and the SNP have
been making together over the last three
years in terms of HO brexit as bad at
exactly the same wrongheaded arguments
against Scottish independence a border
between the two nations a separate
currency a relationship with your
closest and best trading partner which
is England so these issues that exactly
the same and a Scottish context as they
were arguing against brexit I mean
you've said it before I wonder if you'll
say it again that do you your view is in
essence that there should be less
top-down control of the Scottish Labour
Party but not autonomy why not
well the Scottish Labour Party has
complete autonomy already people
misunderstand this there's been a
process since 2011 the previous leaders
have taken through in the autonomy is
not used so why don't use all of the
autonomy of the Scottish Labour Party
first and then see where that goes
however I want to as deputy leader not
just look at how we govern the country
and how many parts of the people of this
country can govern themselves over the
course of the post breaks at Britain
within the UK context but the Labour
Party has to do the same to and give
much more power to regional directors
and regional offices but it's very
similar to the Scottish Parliament the
SNP don't use the full autonomy they
have at the Scottish parliamentary level
and we don't use it full autonomy or
have that Scottish Labour Party they
look let's use them let's do it properly
let's reform the internal workings of
the Labour Party and trying to win the
next election in running good to see
thank you so much indeed